ist das interstellare objekt obama doch
einer alien sonder oder zumindest ein
überrest ein forschungsteam hat jetzt
die bahn durch unser sonnensystem
überprüft und festgestellt dass dieses
objekt viel zu leicht für ein objekt aus
stein oder eis war so weder ein asteroid
oder ein komet sein kann und sie konnten
sogar ausrechnen wie diese sonde
beschaffen war
wir fassen ja alle fakten zusammen und
kommen zu einem wirklich unglaublichen
schluss und er ist wirklich meint neuen
klicks und science fiction
hier gibt es täglich science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
verrückt verrückt verrückt was hat uns
da im september letzten jahres besucht
ein brocken aus gestein oder eis kann es
nicht gewesen sein
schon früh sieht es aus wie beim kometen
dafür hätte das objekt in der nähe der
sonne verdampfen müssen und jetzt ist
auch gestein aus dem rennen
die flugbahn passt einfach nicht zu
einem objekt aus gestein und es ist
immer mehr mysteriös an diesem objekt
werden dabei berichtet ein
forschungsteam der indische trade flur
listen hatte eine große aktion gestartet
mit radioteleskopen wollten sie den
mysteriösen brocken über mehrere
frequenzen abhören wo kommt humor
woraus besteht er sendete er signale
außerirdischer intelligenz aber es wird
alles ruhig doch das ändert nichts daran
obama bleibt mehr als mysteriös und
forschungsteams weltweit suchen
fieberhaft nach neuen erkenntnissen oder
zumindest hinweisen um seine identität
zu klären denn es sind mehr fragen offen
als beantwortet fest steht nur es
handelt sich um das erste interstellare
objekt das nicht aus unserem
sonnensystem stammt und dessen durchflug
wir beobachten konnten humor ist das
erste interstellare objekt das eindeutig
identifiziert werden konnte wegen ihm
gibt es jetzt eine neue kategorie der
internationalen astronomischen union ii
für inter steller wir haben es sie also
mit 1 zu tun
und als sie hat wirklich ziemlich
verrückte eigenschaften wie jetzt schwul
bi ali und am rand von der harvard
university herausbekommen haben demnach
und jetzt bitte festhalten so wie es
sich beim flug durch unser sonnensystem
verhalten hat vor allem wie stark es
sich durch den sonnen druck
beschleunigen ließ hatte es einen radius
von 20 metern und 8
eine dicke von 0,3 bis 0,9 millimetern
bei einer länge von 1800 metern wort das
ist wirklich der absolute wahnsinn wie
kann das sein
es gibt zwei erklärungen und einer davon
ist ziemlich unwahrscheinlich die eine
ist dass es sich über ein neues
natürlich vorkommendes super dieses
material handelt und die andere
das ist eine alien sonde oder überreste
einer alien sonne sind und das
unwahrscheinlichste ist hier das ist
natürliches material sein könnte
insbesondere da sie beim vorbeiflug an
der sonde als perfekter reflektor
herausgestellt hat so schnell wurde es
beschleunigt hierbei gibt es jetzt zwei
thesen weltraumschrott einer fremden
zivilisationen oder eine sonde die ganz
bewusst zu uns geschickt wurde um daten
über die erde zu gewinnen
zitat wenn wir eine künstliche her kommt
in betracht ziehen so wäre es eine
möglichkeit dass es sich um einen im
interstellaren raum treiben das licht
säge als reste eines fortschrittlichen
technologischen gerät handelt nicht
segeln mit ganz ähnlichen dimensionen
wurden bereits von unserer eigenen
zivilisation angedacht und entwickelt
etwa von ikarus projekt oder der
breakthrough star statistik die licht
segel technologie könnte vielfach etwa
für den transport zwischen einzelnen
planeten oder sternensystemen genutzt
werden
und auch hier gibt es wieder eine
unwahrscheinliche und eine
wahrscheinliche vermutung als
trümmerteil das nur zufällig durch unser
sonnensystem geflogen wäre würde es
rückschlüsse auf die anzahl solcher
objekte in unserem sonnensystem geben
und das wären achtung eine billiarde
solcher objekte pro sternensystem
gegenüber universe today sagte lück die
alternative ist sich vorzustellen dass
obama auf einer aufklärungsmission war
der grund aus dem ich über die
aufklärungsmöglichkeiten nachdenke
besteht darin dass die annahme dass mon
amour einer zufälligen umlauf waren
folgte die erzeugung von achtung
ungefähr 10 15 objekten pro stern in
unserer galaxie erfordert diese fülle
ist bis zu 100 millionen mal höher als
vom sonnensystem erwartet basierend auf
einer berechnung die wir im jahr 2009
durchgeführt haben ein überraschend
hoher überfluss präsident obama ist eine
gezielte erkundung einer
aufklärungsmission und kein mitglied
einer zufälligen population von objekten
und in diesen berechnungen da geht es
noch um natürliche objekte also wie
sollen so viele künstliche objekte wie
gesagt pro stern durch unsere galaxie
fliegen da ist dann im moment nur noch
eine erklärung plausibel obama muss
eigentlich zwingend eine alien sonst
sein und das eigentlich für mich nur ein
weil wie soll ich hier und wie soll loeb
so eine behauptung aufstellen ohne sich
auf sehr dünnes eis zu begeben
wir können keine daten mehr gewinnen das
ist wirklich ein problem die sonne ist
weg geht aber trotzdem noch einen
schritt weiter er vermutet dass es sich
ursprünglich um eine ganze armada
solcher sonder gehandelt haben könnte
und nur eine dieser sondern es geschafft
hat wirklich unser sonnensystem zu
treffen bzw
wer nur eine der sonden entdeckt haben
und jetzt könnte man natürlich mal
gucken wer diese überhaupt ist
vielleicht ist es ja irgendein spinner
der herr irgendwelchen blödsinn
verbreitet aber weit sogar ziemlich weit
gefehlt loeb ist niemand geringeres als
professor für astrophysik an harvard
university direktor des institute for
crm computation dem harvard smithsonian
center for astrophysics und vorsitzender
des fachbereiches astronomie der harvard
university
ob sie das ist jetzt ja mal richtig
seriös jetzt bleibt nur noch eine frage
woher und auch da wissen wir etwas 1 eu
marmor kam aus der richtung des sterns
wega im sternbild leier und drang von
oben in unser sonnensystem ein wir
sollten also mal ganz schnell unsere
teleskope in diese richtung drehen und
nachsehen
wie es genau dort den etwa 25
lichtjahren entfernung so aussieht es
wäre nicht verwunderlich wenn wir da
einen exoplaneten mit idealen
bedingungen finden würden im orbit von
vega selbst ist das eigentlich eher
unwahrscheinlich dort rotiert eine
scheibe aus staub rund um den stern er
stammt wahrscheinlich aus der kollision
zweier planeten wir müssen also etwas
genauer hinschauen wenn ihr kein video
dazu verpassen und wir werden das sehr
intensiv dran laden dann abonniert am
besten auch den englischen kanal dafür
hier draufklicken vom klicks und da gibt
es auch die ein oder andere video
premiere locker natürlich nicht
vergessen ja und da drunter geht es
weiter mit first picture of birds and
stay tuned see you soon